you don't have a viable candidate except
Jeb Bush who won't get the nomination
because the Republican Party is
disintegrating as we speak you're a
bunch of jokes all of you on the and the
debate next week is not about
Republicans having coming up with coming
up with great ideas because you have no
ideas the debate next week is watching
Donald Trump destroy every one of these
jobs including ben Carson are you
fearful that Donald Trump's about to
destroy you dr. Carson not in the
slightest and the good thing is you know
credit travel around the country before
just tremendous crowds with a great
enthusiasm who in fact understand what
is going on are waking up I've had so
many people who have never voted before
never contributed before who've gotten
involved we have over 300,000 donations
which is growing every day I'm not
necessarily going after the big money or
the special interest groups because this
is the country that was supposed to be
about the people for of and by the
people not for them by the government
not four of them by the special interest
groups and I think the promise of
America is yet to be realized and I
think it can be a great nation which can
lead the world in the right direction
once again but